in your opinion do you think he poses a
threat to britain
of course look you know there's no doubt
in my mind that
even then when i was working with him
and he you know we got a chance to sort
of get him to see things a little bit
differently
and i thought it would take us you know
a little bit more time to get it to see
things completely differently but
for him to say now that he's you know
he's made a mistake i mean look you know
there's a lot there's lots to think
about here one is being incarcerated
he's potentially going to face a heavy
you know a long prison sentence
potentially even death
but also he's also been they've also
been ditched by the leadership of isis
so there's
a number of things that are going on
here but i would still say he poses a
threat
but we can turn that threat into promise
if we
get a chance to work with the individual
you tried to
uh help him didn't you in a period 2015
2016 uh yet he is still out there so
what happened
well over the over the course of the
time that we were working with him you
know it was confrontational but
i see when you when you're having an
intervention with an individual like him
um and you've got like a debate going
and that's healthy you know to have a
conversation was the first
part of an intervention the the you know
we we were getting
uh along pretty good we were moving
along we were getting them to see things
a little bit differently we were having
the conversations
the dialogue um but then all of a sudden
you know the
leadership race for the pm's office
became quite open for theresa may and
this was too risky of a case for for me
to be working with whilst being funded
by the government
um how how was it too risky if you'd
made all this headway and suddenly
uh the leadership campaign came up
well because the the parents
unfortunately you know against
our advice against other people advising
them um
decided to send money anyway to jack and
that was obviously as you know
it's a it's an offense and they just we
saw it over the last few weeks you know
that they almost
were imprisoned and because an
investigation was around the family and
around the case
we were when i was a government funded
and a government supported
intervention provider at that time it
was quite sensitive for the
for the the home secretary at the time
whilst buying for the
the you know for the leadership of the
the conservatives
the advisors didn't want any negative
media coverage around theresa may at
that time so
we got dropped it was as simple as that
unfortunately
our you know programs like this
interventions at a level
you know a high risk level became
something that was too risky
for the pm and the home sector at that
time um to be taken on because of
what was going on with her political
career and non-political ambitions
unfortunately you're actually saying
though
so are you saying that the parents what
what they did by sending money which
uh as we know on friday they were
convicted and were given a suspended
sentence are you saying
that what they did in sending this money
jeopardized what you were doing
absolutely because they broke the law
and by breaking the law it became an
investigation a criminal investigation
around the family around me as an
intervention provider um you know
things needed to be looked at was
whether to whether to sort of look at
how we were advising or
not advising the family and because of
that investigation at a time when it was
very important for theresa may to become
pm became too much of a risky
business so people like me got dropped
and unfortunately so did
all of the serious and high-risk
intervention work that came along with
the work that i did
and that's a unfortunate reality of the
way politics go here but
with regards to the family you know it's
it's sad that they're going through this
i i appreciate that you know that they
wanted to do everything for their for
their child
but at the same time you know the law is
the law and unfortunately they broke
that
when you last had contact with jack
let's what was this 2016
how far had you got in your attempts
to try to de-radicalize him
well we managed to get him clock climbed
down from 10 steps to run about seven
steps where he
i started to apologize to the way he was
taking speaking to his parents
he started to apologize with some of the
abrupt and you know disrespectful
behavior
he showed towards me and then he started
to talk about how he
kind of differed with the ideology of
isis
but uh his difference of opinion around
that
and my difference of the opinion around
that may be different and those were his
words
but it was a climb down there was a
significant climb down from where we
started
but it was it was it was it was good for
us because it gave us an opportunity
to turn a potential threat
uh like him into a potential promise and
it was about disc we started to discuss
you know ways of escaping ways out and
that's why i think
the mother was so um emotionally driven
to try to help
him get away but and she wanted to send
him money because she thought that
that money may help him escape and of
course
we've seen in our we've just seen in our
interview with him he says he
misses his mother but he has admitted at
one time he was prepared to carry out a
suicide attack so what would be the
reaction
uh in the uk if he were to try to get
back
do you feel i think i think the people
in the uk have got a right to have
their they know their their belief that
he's a threat and he's made his decision
and he should never be able to be
allowed back i understand that and
appreciate that
however from an expert's perspective
working with individuals like that
we've got a problem in our society we've
got a you know radicalization and
extremism is
is growing on both sides of the divide
whether it's far right or whether it's
from a religious perspective
and i look at individuals like jack
as potential opportunities to tone those
threats
to rehabilitate them to reintegrate them
and make them tools and assets
to protect others from being radicalized
or driven down the same path
and to follow an ideology like isis so i
would look at that as an opportunity
potentially
and if he doesn't if he doesn't
reintegrate and if he doesn't
he's in prison and he would be in prison
for a very long time but i
would emphasize that with people like
that we need to work with them
to turn the system around to make them
assets and tools
to prevent others and safeguard our
society